prospects are favorable for further
improvement in the US labor market and
the economy more broadly low oil prices
and ongoing employment gains should
continue to bolster consumer spending
financial conditions generally remain
supportive of growth and the highly
accommodative monetary policies abroad
should work to strengthen global growth
conditions likely would make it
appropriate at some point this year to
raise the federal funds rate target the
importance of the initial step to raise
the federal funds rate target should not
be overemphasized what matters for
financial conditions and the broader
economy is the entire expected path of
interest rates we have no judgment about
at this point about the appropriate date
to raise the federal funds rate an
advantage the beginning a little bit
earlier is that we might have a more
gradual path of rate increases we're not
going to raise rates if we think it's
going to tip the economy into a
recession doing so when we finally begin
in the deliberate and gradual way
looking at what the impact of those
decisions are on the economy strikes me
as a prudent a prudent approach I do
think the economy has improved a great
deal and in a way I'm focused on the
economy strength and its good
performance rather than mainly lying
awake at night and worrying about a
further down turn our economy is in a
much better state low interest rates
have facilitated it and a decision on
our part to raise rates will say no the
economy doesn't stink we're close to
where we want to be and we now think the
economy can not only tolerate but needs
our rates